un peu de pression mais là il faut de
concentrer ses salue aujourd'hui berino
va se concentrer
ouais c'était la première fois de ma vie
que je me concentre donc soyez bien
attentifs
concentrez-vous sur ma concentration
vérino c'est la première personne qui a
pris une vidéo avec moi cette année
depuis le début de l'année je donne
plein de conseils sur la mémoire et on
n'a jamais vu ce que ça donnait en live
a essayé de la prendre à quelqu'un parce
que c'est rapide ou pas est-ce que c'est
faisable ou pas ouais on est dans la
grande question c'est pour ça que j'ai
de la pression c'est pour ça que je sens
que j'ai pas envie de devant tous ses
abonnés que les gens réalisent n'en ai
que j'ai un regard sont pas nombreux
non à venir ouais ou alors je pour une
fois je mets petite [ __ ] a cliqué
personnes regardant la vidéo la vidéo va
être forcément un petit peu lent que je
pense que je vais accélérer n'est pas
sage mais je vais essayer de donner des
images clés mental associé au chiffre de
havre hockey ahl chiffres de la fin les
nombres de à 20 aussi si tu veux alors
des images clés associés aux chiffres on
va essayer de le faire soit en rimes
soit avec marche plus pour toi quand je
te dis 1 le chiffre 1
il te fait penser à quelle image un
viking 1 viking's way et la b to b c'est
que c'est un truc qui utilisait souvent
que les mots techniques pour le 1ier
voilà le 2ième ferait penser le 2 2 le 2
je vois juste deux doigts comme ça je
crois d'accord c'est pas très fort moi
je me propose de mettre du feu de feu
d'accord parce que ça va gérer ça marche
très bien mais ça on peut faire cramer
des choses après plus tard d'un soleil
noir c'est plutôt pas mal
ok ok trois sets je pense à quoi voit
par le son soit par l'image en est de
même du 3-3 une croix une seconde balle
100 m 4 c'est à dire car c'est plus dur
4 un charme et pas l'anglais mais 4 6 6
1 6 6
enfin dans ces femmes enceintes à une
réforme du système ça ouais à latence
est sinon qu'est ce qu'on a je veux
proposer une tête et dans ce cas là tu
penses à quelqu'un qui n'a pas peut-être
justement d'accord une huître oui ok ok
bah je vais vous inviteront à l'ouvrir
et pour voir la paire voilà avec et en
plus elle aurait deux formes de route
est mal à 99.99 pour dix 10 1 une 6ème
six suspects moi j'ai un flic dans un
commissariat dans ma tête
pourquoi police mais c'est pas mon ma
meilleure image non c'est vrai que mais
c'est en images c'est toi qui l'a jamais
évoqué m
j'avais un peu la pression je t'avoue
mais ça ne disparaisse 10 police
ok ok l'intérieur on va à 20 pas ouais
ouais ok 11g penseur de rodin expirent
en bronze
exactement ok 12 g de la pelouse mais
pas n'importe laquelle celle que j'avais
dans ma première maison
donc c'est à dire ces animaux je connais
bien si tu prends la pelouse en 12 il
faut que ce soit une plus que tu connais
un jardin en fait au delà de la pelouse
tu vois donc c'est la pelouse des
vacances sur la petite maison je crois
qu'on n'avait pas le savoir c'est la
pelouse où j'ai enterré mon meilleur il
ya deux jours 13 la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que du coup t'es pas mon meilleur
un littéraire ou alors la vidéo sortira
sa mort elle est dans une vie où les cas
il ya un indice quelque part dans une
vidéo treize mois j'ai baisse donc j'ai
un couple est en train de l'ordre de
procréer savard 14,1 à 1,4 à ce qu'on
mettrait pas le bateau avec un marron
plus où il n'ya pas de voile un homme
sur la planche à voile
moi j'ai un sucre d'orge c'était donc
les vols dégradations graves et 16
j'ai un couple qui baise non là on va
mettre une fraise comme ça c'est
intéressant ça peut être perturbant
ok je me mets des petits défis yamaha
ouais moi j'appellerai la police en fait
là pour le coup le problème c'est que
police on l'avait jamais rien dit sur
sept alors a vendu pour chaussettes
chaussettes ok je te ferai une chemin
vers la police puis les choses à nous
un flic en chaussettes 18 18 18 18
points 6 sur 1,8 c'était bien tu
proposes quoi tend ainsi ainsi hockey 19
19 mois j'ai dans mon panier 9 mai alors
du coup ça sera pas senti un panier neuf
semaines ça et enfin en iran 20 20 donc
là en fin de cette vidéo aussi d'avoir
joué 12 minutes enfin moins de 12
minutes parce qu'on a parlé au départ en
12 minutes vérino a construit et a pris
une table de rappel de 0,1
ne faites pas ça chez vous maintenant on
va voir si tu es capable de s'en servir
donc je vais te donner 20 mo hockey et
tu vas les mémoriser dans ta tête de 1 à
20 ok pour les mémoriser tu va associer
le mourre que je te donne avec l'image
qui est en fait tu vas essayer de faire
les images les plus marquantes possible
si par exemple je te donnais un casque
en un
ouais faudrait surtout pas t'imaginer
ton 1 avec un casque de 1
ouais parce que tu lui ouvrirait facile
raconte avec un casque de moto sur une
moto directement da gloria se tiendrait
mieux qu'une image et ça s'est vu à
l'écran qu'en vrai c'est ce que j'allais
faire de voir le casque et je me faisais
si bien si le casque allez je te propose
en un
un peu de voitures un peu notre voiture
même pas réfléchi au téléphone portable
un téléphone portable
ok donc un samsung a priori en trois un
perroquet d'accord en 4 je vais te
demandé d'imaginer un extrême je demande
et l'image du 4 alors c'est un coup
planche à voile avec un extincteur
allumé et du coup il va plus et elle va
plus vite
d'accord ça c'est pas mal ouais moi je
pense que j'avais imaginé mais qui fait
de la planche à voile sur de la mousse
ah oui en fait la moue s'était faite par
extincteur mais on est sur le même
principe vrai de grossir grossir elles
font n'importe quoi
ok 25 une moto au mans
et bien maintenant on va voir si ça
fonctionne une méthode est est ce que ça
vaut le coup de passer les 12 minutes de
départ à avoir une table de rappel pour
pour apprécié d'apprendre la réponse est
évidemment
alors quand je te demande maintenant
j'ai donné les numéros un peu dans le
désordre
ouais il me donnes pas ton image de tap
te rappelles mais c'est le donnent le
mot que tu m'as donné mais tant qu en
fait essayer de retenir un discours au
numéro de téléphone ou ce genre de
choses
quoi c'est ça que je veux voir si tu
arrives et en services quoi en 12 ans
n'avait on avait un manteau exact en
cinq ans un conte avait une moto ya 107
en sept ans n'avait rien
mieux en quatorze en 14 on avait une
fiche et celui là 14 et les lunettes
yes en 11 en avait 11 ans n'avait
ça c'est sûr exact mais j'étais pas prêt
mais oui un petit coquin à catane où les
mots et essaye de dire ça s'est arrangé
en tel cas nature à cheveux cheveux ses
seize pièces en perroquet perroquet
c'est le trois pièces le
les lunettes les lunettes c'est
c'est le sucre d'orge le 14 et le moulin
à vent et le moulin à vent c'est le 13
iev tu essayes de tous les instituts et
d'un coup ouais en partant de la fin en
partant de l'histoire évidemment alors
en vain c'est une table correct en 19
c'est un canard oui en 18 c 18 18 18
chaque table où je cherche tout c'est
pas vraiment ouais je cherche la table
18 c voyez le 18 c'est vraiment l'image
qui est pas venu lui au départ car un
truc que j'ai donné il a pris tout de
suite passé lors le chauffage des 17,17
c'est la brosse à dents louis saez c'est
des cheveux parce qu'on avait déjà dit
en avait 16
est ce qu'on avait déjà fait ou pas une
fois tout à l'heure - ouais enfin dans
le premier mais le premier truc qui me
l'a fait wayne c'est pour montrer aussi
qu'on a une mémoire de ce conte à
repasser ou pas là c est le cas de ce
qu'on avait déjà fait et le 15 à ce
qu'on avait déjà fait non on n'avait pas
déjà fait et le 15 c'est donc
[Musique]
c'est un casque de moto
non ça c'est un truc que tu m'a dit vous
allez vraiment l'a pas fait on devrait
pas pareil pour la fin est maintenant
venir me chercher la vraie image que
j'aille chercher leur image
ah oui bah c'est le king oui mais c'est
quoi qu'on a mis on a vraiment mis à
quelque chose a évoqué alors en un
on a dû mettre un pneu exact et ça
c'était pour vous faire voir qu'on peut
écraser une table de rappel avec un
autre objet mais il faut qu'on ait une
image bien fort pourquoi virer votre
[ __ ] c'est fort en quatre minutes on a
réussi à racheter laisse le papier merci
pour ne lit pas le regarde pas mais
surprend toi demain d'accord de dire
tiens je vais essayer de m'en faire tu
le donnes à ta femme et lui demandent
qu'à t'interroges toi tu il y en a qui
vont virer les moins forts écoute c'est
dingue parce que en vue en vrai je suis
arrivé en me disant je vais échoué je
vraiment pas vous mentir je suis arrivé
en me disant c'est bien ça va être une
vidéo marrante vous fabien olicard va me
montrer que je suis un teubé et j'étais
sûr de ça donc je suis vraiment pour le
coup même encore plus bluffé que sur la
prochaine la première vidéo qu'on avait
fait parce que c'est la première vidéo
j'étais encore avec toi même çà et là ce
que tu es et ce que tu ça peut faire est
ce qu'on a toujours fait croire que tu
savais pas faire exactement à la plupart
des gens mais manquant je donnais des
formations quoi dit oui mais c'est très
long du coup comme processus à prendre
c'est moins long que d'essayer
d'apprendre des choses parker sa part du
fait tomber toujours ce que vous comptez
sur google maps et qu'il dit tout droit
il ya 10 minutes de bouchons mais si tu
fais ça tu veux bizarrement économiser
du temps mais c'est vrai et du carburant
parce que du coup ça va tenir
extrêmement longtemps sur ces filous
qu'apple merci philippe roche produit
philippe roche irl terran une [ __ ]
c'est incroyable ça moi j'aimerais bien
dire que tous les gens de cette vidéo si
jamais vous avez envie de venir sur mal
ma chaîne à moi tous les gens qui ont
tendance à écrire des trucs débiles en
commentaire ne venez pas vous ne
m'intéressait pas du pas du tout envie
de vous parler
ça c'est dit c'est bon vous qu'on a une
discussion à ce sujet c'est que le
raisin segment et et tous les autres je
vous invite à découvrir vérino si vous
connaissez pas
il met une vidéo tous les samedis matin
à 11 heures que ça valide ont internet
ils filment ça en public à la fin de son
spectacle avec le public derrière moi je
tourne le vendredi soir alors il y en a
qui l'on se pose la question de savoir
déjà c'est un fonds vert de deux est ce
que tu fais tout son spectacle de dorval
évidemment évidemment je vais jouer
pendant une heure comme ça avec des gens
qui ont fait rire de voice c'est lui qui
décide s'il s'entend même pas j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu et surtout
qu'elle va vous motiver vous aussi à
vous servir de votre mémoire un peu
différemment
rappelez vous qu'il ya une playlist qui
concerne tous les trucs de mémoire je
vous la remettrait dans la description
si vous avez aimé n'hésitez pas à nous
faire savoir en mettant un petit pouce
en l'air il ya des pouces en l'air vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne découvert celle de vérino
également en cliquant ici ça va être à
peu près par là et rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao ciao
dallas
[Musique]